e
after 2 stunningly subpar
meetings with Mexico and
Guatemala will
discuss it.
>> Number one, it's very
dangers, check because a lot of
which is seen as a tax on be
quite frankly are attacks on
science so if you are trying to
get at me you really attacking
not only doctor Anthony Fauci
you're attacking science if you
believe this starting to crack.
>> The almighty Fauci makes it
clear criticize me you're
criticizing science really one
of the doctors, scientists
criticize you do they not like
science their own profession
with more on this taking doctor
Anthony Fauci side
is patchy apologies. Jesse He
is a co-host of the 5 hostages
waters world on Saturdays at 8
and author of the upcoming book
comes out in July 6th. How I
saved the world,
so Jesse yes, I did not know
when he said this I wasn't
issued yesterday did you guys
tackle this on the 5 we're
going to tackle it tonight on
the FOX came out after
it did. So yeah, I mean your
thoughts your is outrage and I
was over in a guy I've seen in
my life.
>> So when you attack a liberal
this is what they do. They say
oh you're attacking women,
you're attacking me because I'm
black you're you're you're
you're attacking the media,
so they try to then assume this
grand identity you're attacking
science. No we're not
even attacking science were
were criticizing you doctor
Fauci and he should be able to
take the Heat.
>> I don't know if Chuck Todd
followed up and said well
doctor fact, the critics would
say that you did have it wrong
and mask you did have it wrong
on how much danger this
pandemic would be you did have
it wrong to marginalize the
Wuhan lab leak.
He did have it wrong saying
services or a place you can
catch the virus you did have it
wrong when it said
you can catch it outside so I
don't know did he I it's more
than likely if he had followed
up like that.
>> It would be in the news but
I give him the benefit of the
doubt. He is so defensive.
He's also referring to himself
in the 3rd person listened to
the whole by them not going to
a boy with the we got the gist
of it. He actually first
himself if you insult doctor
Fauci excuse me are you doctor
Fauci well as someone that
likes to refer to himself in
the 3rd person I'm not going
that Brian but you're right he
was your honor your World is
low unified. That's right
wrong
on masks. He's criticize
DeSantis was the hero Cuomo was
the villain. He got it all
wrong. So we're not really
criticizing science we're just
saying listen. You got it
wrong. What a half
dozen times. Let's let's let's
get it together and get it
right so it doesn't happen
again since we are not
scientists we could have a soul
who you know in that doctor
Peter mccullough is his
cardiologist internist and
epidemiologist and he it Laura
last night.
>> So your witness
cut 13.
>> Well or as a practicing
doctor and as a manager of 2
major journals. I can tell you
you know we hear from lawyers
that no person is above the law
and in medicine no doctor is
above peer review
and what Americans really
deserve to see over the last
year is a team of doctors
prefer bleed doctors who
actually knew how to treat
patients with COVID-19 knew how
to rapidly interpret the
literature and come up with a
cracked differences, you know
the science changed over time,
and every time there was a
definitive statement within a
few days or a few weeks.
There are new data coming out
as particularly with respect to
treatment.
>> We notice civilians.
I think by the time though his
book comes out November, 13 oh
it's all about July 6th with as
by the time his book comes out
November, 3rd I think he's
going to be
totally disgraced. I did 2
before unlike Cuomo he got it
right after he's going to get
it before I did so and that
advance whatever he got I hope
it wasn't more than what I got
for how I save the world
because that's a disgraced is
in a very similar book.
>> And yet a woman's longer
-300 pages he was only 18 his
his 80 Arab doctor should
monitor but you're right so it
wasn't just. He was following
the science and the science
developed he was getting
e-mails from scientific
leadership saying it looks like
the sequence
never mutated it looks like
this was a manipulator and then
he got on a conference call
with the scientists. They did a
one 80
and put out a paper and says no
no no it came from an animal,
so he was actually it was a
scientific conspiracy to then
block scientific research into
the truth.
>> All right I got to breed to
something else drive me not to
have not been able to focus on
and that is I do Joe Pa Joe
Biden's foreign policy
instincts and track record
there's 2 things that worry
about this climate change
agenda. This destroying our
energy our fossil fuel which
has been literally the engine
of our economy. This high
dry. The fracking that has
allowed us to the ship and use
natural gas
and of course the oiled the
drilling that's been taking
place he's getting rid of all
that page 6 of the Wall Street
Journal today, not only is
China not doing that
they say they're more can
moving away from whatever they
agreed to in the Paris climate
change they said their focus is
going to be on reviving
their economy. That's what our
focus should be this is
president Biden same too an
audience in England.
What he's Joint Chiefs of Staff
are telling him cut 3.
>> I
>> fire a mall.
I would say listen is that true
we do as well OK Rogan I don't
believe have a uniform, I don't
believe that doing toy that I
think he made it up the better
and I think he made it up
they'll be actually the good
side of the story. And I
thought the biggest threat was
white supremacy.
Right you want various threat
i-four last year was Russia
right and then it was China
so like every other week, it's
a different threat so.
He instead of after the first
had this is the message.
Vladimir putin sending us and
he's representing us.
>> After the first hack.
They were so scared about of
retribution they hit us again
from the same country this time
first they got or oil and gas.
Then they eat right,
then they said you know human
rights is going to come up
navalny's health matters to us
no they said his organization
is now illegal. There's no sign
is ever going to get out deals
arrested 2 more dissidents in
the meantime these are messages
sent to Joe Biden to make him
uncomfortable. This is a quote
from the far MR. on the
doorstep of their meeting in
Vienna in a few days,
this is a disaster Joe Biden
has to defend big beef
and the United States big beef
and big oil, it's barbecue
season, Brian we need to be
able to barbecue this beef.
>> I would if I were the
president right before I sat
down with Vladimir putin I have
the Defense Department launched
a cyber attack on raw snapped
the big oil company right there
so he finds out during the
meeting. The biggest oil
company in Russia just got
hacked and then afterwards,
I'd say we're going to now re
up on all the military package
to Ukraine
big satellite imagery shipment
I I'd lock in with all the
tactical armaments because they
have snipers in the East that
are crushing the Ukrainians and
that's what I do I'd sandwich
putin with those 2 deals and I
would force him to say
next attack from the Russian
soil on America.
I'm holding the Kremlin
personally responsible I am I
overstating what I say kamala
Harris as disasters today trip
I think that's
about right.
>> the is what were your
expectations. The right, I mean
did you really think she was
going down there to solve
problems, she's buying time
just want to go to the border
says what photographs of her
with border agents at a
wall praising Border Patrol
agent she wants to run for
president one day that will
just be an ad against her by
someone say they can say
you know, she's tough an
immigrant she is mean she's
nasty she's pro Border. Patrol,
just what those images out
there so she's doing she's tap
dancing and avoiding the
problem all right 180,000.
You know that number is that
that's who have crossed into
173 the month before. The
problem is though the the
the problem getting worse in
real time as I headed you
handle that when you first
kicked off and all those kids
were coming across Well, it's
actually still happening.
>> What do we open up to with
this week on Monday a 5
year-old walking around by
herself in front of the wall.
>> And then you see a border
agent grabbed one of these
images would have been the
image we never forgot about
Trump ingrained in our minds
and our psyche for ever.
So she's got an unfolding
problem an agency Henrik y our
today called on Biden and
Harris to let the
local people led the with the
local residents understand that
you care and come down to the
border. Coy I don't need to
tell you a Democrat I think
that I think they could have a
hard time out running this
problem. Well, you know it gets
really hot in the summer so
this migration patterns
naturally going to die down so
they'll just Pat themselves on
the back and claim that they
fixed it, but it's just going
to be just as bad next year
because they're not changing
any of the policies I think
they're going to get rocked in
the midterms immigration is a
hot-button issue you read this.
>> And I think it's a harbinger
of things to come people are
upset about it,
especially people in Texas
they're trying to turn Texas
blue Brian Cup that's what
they're trying to do right, but
it's going the other way right
now and here's the other thing
that but politically right now
it's going the other way but if
you have hundreds of thousands
of illegal immigrants pouring
into Texas. It's a lot of
women, you know they
have babies they're going to if
they get in the state if they
get asylum they're going to
vote Democrat first year
generation immigrants always
vote Democrat that's the game.
They're going to suffer early.
Short term consequences, b